let's bring in Republican congresswoman
from New York Claudia Tenny uh
congresswoman thank you for coming on I
mean the reason that Americans and we've
talked about this a little bit are so
anxious about terrorism is because we
have essentially opened the door and
allowed terrorists to come into our
country well exactly trace and I just
first want to say uh my deepest
condolences to the family and and very
sorry for what happened this is a a
tragedy but it is a cautionary tale
because while the governor is sitting
there talk
about uh what happened here and luckily
this was not a terrorist action but it
was a tragedy nonetheless uh we have a
an open border and as we've talked about
many times I've been sounding the alarm
since March I visited with the Customs
and Border Patrol we started the C uh
the the northern border security caucus
and you've heard this over and over I
said it I've been saying this for weeks
over 85% of the of the people on the
foreign terrorist watch list have come
across the northern border and New York
doesn't help New York issues Kathy hokel
issues valid driver's licenses to these
illegal immigrants and they can go
anywhere they want in New York or across
the country and on top of that under
Governor Cuomo they passed what they
call the green light law which makes it
very difficult for our homeland security
our Customs and Border Patrol to find
out and get information from New York
State about illegal immigrants about
people who've been issued driver's
licenses so there's a real problem with
our ability to get information and to
vet people coming into the state of New
York so we're not out of the woods this
is a very dangerous time with what's
happening overseas and this Invasion at
our border and and the truth is if
today's incident did turn out to be
terrorism nobody would have been
surprised and that sets a very bad
precedent yeah it's this is Terri I mean
look we and New York are incentivizing
this Invasion into our into our side uh
we've got a huge problem across the
country and all of these Democrat
politicians in New York are complicit
Kathy hokel our governor mayor Adams
they incentivizing and giving all this
money to get people to come here and
they're being human traffic the the
cartels are making money uh these people
some of them are are really just traffic
they're not necessarily the bad guys but
in between all these other people the
customs in Border Patrol are handcuff
they can't figure out who's the bad guy
and who's here being trafficked so we
have got to be vigilant and we've got to
put pressure on these politicians who do
not stand up for security and who are
not keeping uh the American taxpayers
safe I I think people are putting
pressure on the politician at the top
because you look at the numbers I mean
look at the fox poll on President
Biden's job performance on these two key
factors right National Security approval
40% immigration approval
33% I mean those are awful numbers if
you are running for reelection your
final thoughts on this
congresswoman yeah absolutely there's
higher than they should be because I
think it's one of the most significant
risks we face as a country and we see
this unrest around the country around
the world money being pumped into
universities Sanctuary cities that are
protected and supported by New York City
Upstate cities even college campuses we
have got to really start voting these
people out of office and put in people
who understand that their primary
Mission especially on the federal side
with President Biden and the Secretary
of Homeland Security mayorcas is
protecting our border and National
Defense that's it they need to be
focused on that and they're not and
that's why you're you're seeing them uh
sliding in the poll so dramatically yeah
New York congresswoman Claudia Tenny
Happy Thanksgiving to you ma'am thank
you for coming on thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else